ladies and gentlemen have you ever
wondered what's going on in your south
pole have you ever wondered how to do it
like they do it on the Discovery Channel
have you ever had questions but we're
just too afraid to ask your parents
while leg cuddles Uncle Bob my good old
uncle markiplier learn me a thing or two
about how things are done but not in any
graphic way or detail that would be
compromising to the fabric of society so
this is a go forward this is a game
called how do you do it and I don't even
know why I'm playing this but it's it's
about how a little girls just saw the
Titanic and the sex scene and the
Titanic in the car so she's trying to
figure out how in the world whatever the
hell they did was or how that is done
it's totally I don't know damn idea J
and can't rotate the dolls she move your
arms
well basically whatever you're trying to
do the the the stuff the the thing the
thing you you need to make sure to slam
your crotch as hard as you can into your
partner's whatever and then jiggle it
around until something happens and then
the cloud forms in the car and then and
then then then the disgusted face just
like what is what is even all of this oh
what the hell did I do I think I went
wrong in the way of this sex the Kama
Sutra is nothing yeah do you like that
Oh Oh No
wait oh no I don't think I did this
right Oh mother Oh you might have done
the sex 72 times mom saw damn it
all this education that could have
happened it's gone out the window now no
one will be able to learn from this
experience let's try this again because
I remember my sex education when I was a
young lad my dad threw me a book that
basically described to people rubbing
each other until they exploded I think
how what if that's what it was
word-for-word when I was a child oh man
black she's gone
Rose Jack I wasn't even paying attention
to the things that she was saying hmm
this doesn't seem right I mean so long
as we slam our fleshy bits as hard as we
can into they're quite right hey God let
me try to align docking sequence oh wait
they got to go all the way around cuz
that's how normal humans work when
they're dangling from arms that is
happening here yep nothing at all no no
no no nothing that was good of us to
watch the Titanic the other it's great
okay with it you might have done the sex
59 times and you didn't get caught great
everyone accomplished what they wanted
to do today this was a wholesome and
educational experience for the whole
family
I hope you all gathered into your living
room when you watch this all together so
that you could laugh and hopefully not
laugh and then learn because that's
what's really important learning is what
makes the world go round or something
like that ask your parents if you're too
young to know what this is all about
even I don't know what this is all about
my mom what the hell is going on here
no damn idea what's going on in this
game okay thank you all so much for
watching check out the other videos that
I've done that it probably a bit more
appropriate than this one in the
comments in the district somewhere that
will be somewhere and as always I will
see you in